bonjour nadège vous êtes donc un
vainqueur sur place et quelle est donc
la situation en ce moment mais écoutez
un virage je me trouve à quelques
quelques kilomètres du site que va donc
visité emmanuel macron à partir de midi
ici à dunkerque 1 et une manifestation a
été improvisée ce matin donc il y a
plusieurs membres de la cgt que vous
voyez à derrière moi plusieurs avocats
également à ma gauche et puis un
dispositif de sécurité extrêmement
important pour cette quarantaine de
manifestants on retrouve plus d'une
centaine de crs avec une cinquantaine de
véhicules de police également sécurité
et dispositif de sécurité extrêmement
important à l'occasion de la venue d'
emmanuel macron renforcer peut-être
aussi après sa sortie un peu chaotique
et à sa sortie au théâtre vendredi
dernier à laquelle se sont rendus à des
manifestants devant le théâtre des
bouffes du nord dont le voit la
manifestation improvisée par des membres
de la cgt des avocats également contre
la réforme des retraites et contre plus
généralement la politique d' emmanuel
macron alors à l'issue de ce
rassemblement un plusieurs avocats ont
été interpellés par les forces de
l'ordre parmi eux marc devenir qui a été
interpellé ce matin et l'a même été
embarqués par les forces de l'ordre marc
de boni vous êtes vous êtes vice pré
vous êtes vice bâtonnier de dunkerque
racontez moi un peu commencé à dérouler
votre interpellation tout à l'heure et
pour quelles raisons vous interpellez
aujourd'hui les avocats sont présents
ils défendent un principe essentiel qui
est la liberté de manifester
chose tout à fait incompréhensible l'un
de nos confrères a été interpellé sans
avoir commis la moindre infraction avec
ses papiers d'identité et il a été
emmené sans aucun motif sans aucun motif
emmené donc au commissariat de grande
synthe et chose effrayante monsieur le
procureur de la république n'était même
pas informés de la mise en garde à vue
du confrère ce qui constitue en réalité
une irrégularités procédurales manifeste
donc c'est pour ça que vous vous êtes
fait interpeller vous avez refusé le
contrôle d'identité vous n'avez pas
présenter votre pièce d'identité
monsieur le bâtonnier wattez qui est ici
en cours d'interpellation qui a été
empêché de nous rejoindre
mettre en boîte et monsieur le bâtonnier
watts est donc actuellement eux présents
est intervenu auprès du procureur de la
république et a obtenu effectivement si
on se doute que notre confrère soient
immédiatement relâchés
cela étant prêts cela étant précisé le
procureur public n'était même pas
informés de ce qu'un avocat avaient été
mises en garde à vue donc interpellation
que vous jugez à injustifiée non elle
n'est pas injustifiée aller arbitraire
d'accord pourquoi vous êtes venus ici
avec vos collègues pour protester contre
la venue d' emmanuel macron pourquoi
vous êtes là vous nous avons souhaité
rencontrer effectivement monsieur
emmanuel macron ou ses proches pour le
sensibiliser à notre interpellation
les avocats sont en grève depuis
maintenant 15 jours cette grève a été
reconduite de nouveau pendant une
semaine les avocats n'accepte pas la
réforme que l'on veut leur imposer en
termes de régimes de retraite il s'agit
en réalité et bien d'une manifestation
nationale et l'ensemble des deux
barreaux de france et de navarre sont
actuellement en grève pour et bien faire
pression pour le gouvernement auprès du
gouvernement pour pouvoir être
simplement entendus pour faire valoir
effectivement leurs observations
vous espérez encore aujourd'hui pouvoir
vous rapprocher des manuels macro et de
lui parler
un avocat combat jusqu'au bout très bien
merci beaucoup marc de boni donc vous
l'avez entendu amira a les avocats sont
mobilisés aujourd'hui pour à protester
contre cette réforme des retraites
qu'ils jugent qu'elles jugent injuste
ans et est incorrect donc voilà des
avocats mobilisés des membres de la cgt
également qui espérait pouvoir se
rapprocher des manuels macron pour faire
entendre leur mécontentement et bien ça
ne sera visiblement impossible puisque
l'on se trouve déjà à quelques
kilomètres de ce site à d'astrazeneca et
vous le voyez ce dispositif de sécurité
extrêmement important dans que qui a
douché douché leurs espoirs
merci nadège vous étiez donc en direct
de dunkerque